Transcriber: Sude Akgündoğdu
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Merhabalar.
Bateriyle birlikte ben de
sunumumu gerçekleştireceğim.
Öncelikle hepiniz hoşgeldiniz.
Harika gözüküyorsunuz.
Heyecanlandım.
Tabii ki de heyecanı atmak için
önce bir giriş konuşması
yapmak lazım.
Ben İnci Kadribegiç.
İngilizcesi aslında "holy grail,"
yani Türkçe'ye "kutsal kâse"
olarak çevirebileceğimiz
kök hücrelerden
bahsedeceğim ben sizlere.
Öncelikle kök hücrelerimizden
bahsedelim isterseniz,
sona doğru da ben hangi anlara
nasıl tutundum,
bu ana nasıl tutundum,
ondan bahsederiz.
Çok popüler aslında
ülkemizde de, değil mi?
Şu an hepinizin aklında
bir kök hücre figürü var.
İsimler var.
Ama iyi, ama medyatik,
ama bilim insanı olarak.
Gelin biz biraz daha bunun felsefik,
biraz daha arka planını
inceleyelim sizlerle.
Kök hücreyle ilgili bizler
yazılı kaynakları tararken
1800'lerin sonlarına doğru bulabiliyoruz.
Ünlü patolog Rudolf Virchow,
ünlü bir sözü vardır onun.
Demiştir ki,
"Her hücre, kendisini yenileyen
bir başka hücreden meydana gelir."
Aslına bakarsanız, bu kök hücrenin,
yapılmış bugüne kadarki en yalın tabiri.
Akabinde çok geçmeden, 1908'lerde,
Maximow, bu sefer
şöyle bir yorum getirmiştir:
"Tüm kan hücreleri,
tek bir hücreden meydana gelir."
1908'de ortaya attığı bu teoriyi
bizler yıllar sonra kanıtladık
ve 2018'deyiz hâlâ daha
bu teoriyi ispatlamış şekilde,
mekanizmayı doğru kabul ediyoruz.
Bakalım peki,
şimdi kök hücrelerin
tanımından bahsedelim.
Belki biraz aykırılık yapalım
bazı tanımlarda.
Öncelikle şundan bahsedelim isterseniz,
az önce de söyledim, kök hücreler
kendilerini yenileyebilen hücrelerdir.
Hemen buradan bir başka alt başlık açalım.
Kendini yenilemesi aslında onun en önemli
özelliklerinden biri.
İspatlandığı üzere erişkin kök hücreler
kendini gelen uyarılarla
yeniledikten sonra,
köken aldığı hücrenin dışında
farklı bir hücreye dönüşebilir.
"İnci bize örnek ver," derseniz de,
örneğin beyin kök hücrelerimizin
gelen uyarılar doğrultusunda,
sinyaller doğrultusunda
iskelet kası hücresine dönüşmesi gibi.
Bunun ismi plastisite ve bu, biz özellikle
kök hücre araştırmacıları için, çok önemli
bir özelliktir. Hemen buradan daha farklı
bir başlığa atlayalım.
Kendini yenileyebilme özelliğine sahiptir.
Ben az önce yenileme mi dedim? Bahsederken
farklı türlere dönüşme mi dedim?
Özür dilerim,
çok heyecanlıyım çünkü şu anda.
Kusura bakmayın.
Tekrar hemen toparlıyorum.
İlk bahsettiğim özellik,
plastisite özelliği,
farklı hücrelere dönüşebilme özelliğidir.
Dediğim gibi de ispatlandığı üzere,
erişkin kök hücrelerinde,
gelen uyarılar doğrultusunda,
farklı kökenli hücrelere dönüşebiliyor,
beyin kök hücresinin,
iskelet kası hücresine dönüşmesi gibi.
Buradaki kök hücre özelliği,
farklı hücrelere dönüşebilme.
Şimdi bir ikincisi:
Kök hücreler, kendini yenileyebilen ve
özel hücreler oluşturabilen hücrelerdir.
Yenileme, rejenerasyon.
Hemen biraz daha
daha eskilere gidelim.
1800'ler çok yakın olur,
Yunan mitolojisine gidelim.
Yunan mitolojisinde çok çok
çok meşhur bir tanrımız var: Zeus.
Çok çok çok meşhur da bir Titanımız var:
Prometheus.
"Bunları niye anlatıyorsun?"
diyeceksiniz.
Rejeneratif tıp denince aslında böyle
bizlerin hemen aklına gelen
hikâye budur, tarih açısından.
Zamanında Prometheus,
yalnızca Olimpos'un
Tanrılar kısmında ateş var,
insanlar arasında veba yayılıyor,
soğuk çok fazla, ateş yok.
Dolayısıyla, açıkçası burada
bir "tanrılara [karşı] savaşan titan"
lakabını da hak edecek bir şekilde,
bir akşam gidiyor,
ateşi o dağdan alıp,
koşarak aşağı inip, insanlara veriyor.
Tabii ki de bunu duyan Tanrı,
Zeus,
bunu çok ağır bir şekilde
cezalandırmak istiyor.
Ne yapıyor?
Prometheus'u bir kayaya zincirliyor
ve de bir kartal görevlendiriyor.
Kartalın görevi şu:
Sonsuza kadar, o zincirlenen
Prometheus'un karaciğerini yemek.
Şimdi buradan şu şekilde bağlayalım:
Her gün karaciğerini yediği Prometheus'un
ciğeri hemen akşamında tekrar yenileniyor
ve bütün olarak tekrar bulunuyor.
Bu biraz daha halk arasında karaciğer
kendini hemen küçük bir parçası kopsa
bile hemen yenilenir deriz ama aslına
bakarsak bu hücresel süreç en küçük
zararda bile bir yılı falan bulur.
Ama mitoloji!
Biz baktığımız zaman Prometheus'un
karaciğeri kartal tarafından istisnasız
her gün yeniyor, sabaha kadar,
akabinde de o ciğer kendini yeniliyor.
Dolayısıyla o kayaya zincirlenmiş
Prometheus'un ciğerinin sürekli
yenilenmesi kök hücre çalışanları,
rejeneratif tıp alanında faaliyet gösteren
bilim insanları için biraz kurgusal,
tatlı bir örnek diyebiliriz.
Bir diğer özelliği de, biraz daha aykırı
olalım, bazı kaynaklarda geçtiği üzere,
acaba insanın yedek parçasının
üretilmesinin yolunu açan hücreler midir?
Çok güzel bir tartışma konusu olur
ama o belki başka bir TED,
başkaları tarafından sunulacak
belki bir kongre konusu olur.
Şimdi bizler gelin kök hücre nerelerde
nasıl yaşar onlardan bahsedelim.
Kök hücre aslında "niş" adını verdiğimiz
bir mikroçevrede yaşar.
Ben bunlara bekleme odası diyorum.
Çünkü kök hücrelerimiz vücudumuzun
o niş dediğimiz bekleme odalarında
sessiz bir şekilde beklerler.
Gelen olursa, bir sinyal, bir uyarı, hemen
ona cevap verirler.
Yeniden programlanırlar,
farklı hücrelere dönüşürler.
Yine, "bizim sana ihtiyacımız var,
buraya gelmen gerekir,"
dendiği takdirde
hemen göç ederler.
Dolayısıyla kök hücreler vücudumuzda
böyle bağımsız bir şekilde değil,
niş dediğimiz, o bekleme salonu dediğimiz,
o mikroçevrede bulunurlar.
"Başlıca kök hücre kaynakları peki nelerdir,
bu kadar konuştun İnci?"
Kemik iliğidir aslında, hepimizin
bileceği üzere, değil mi?
Kemik iliği nakilleri, hepimiz biliyoruz.
Kısmen nasıl yapıldığına da hakimiz.
Kemik iliği dışında periferik kan, kordon
kanı ve aynı zamanda döllenmeden hemen
sonraki 3-5 gün arasındaki blastosistler
bizlerin kök hücre kaynaklarıdır.
Şimdi, bahsettik kaynaklarımızdan.
Hiyerarşisinden bahsedelim.
Hücrelerde de var maalesef.
Totipotent hücrelerden bahsedelim.
Totipotent hücreler yumurtayla
spermin birleşmesinden,
döllenmeden hemen 3-5
gün sonra oluşan,
embriyonik kök hücrelerimizi barındıran
hücreler aslında.
İçindeki iç hücre kütlesi
bizler için çok önemlidir çünkü o iç
hücre kütlesi dediğimiz hücreler,
istisnasız her biri birer organizma, birer
birey oluşturabilecek hücrelerdir.
Tabi hemen buradan kafanızdaki böyle
görüyorum ben gözlerinizden: Etik sorunlar.
Birazdan oralara da geleceğiz.
Şimdi bahsettik embriyodan,
yine gelin biraz daha geriye gidelim.
Çünkü hücreyle uğraşmak çok keyifli
çünkü esas bence hücre çalışan herkes
gerçekten felsefeyle ilgilenmeli
ve çalıştığı şeyin derinliğini
bir şeyle bağdaştırabilmeli.
Antik çağlara baktığımız zaman,
Antik Yunan'a baktığımız zaman
şöyle demişler Aristo ve çevresi,
eğer döllenen erkekse 40 gün içinde
fetüs oluşuyor, ama döllenen kızsa bu
80 gün içinde oluşur. Aristo biraz daha
ileri gidip şunu iddia etmiştir:
"Dişi embriyoların gelişimi daha da
yavaştır,"diye bir cinsiyetçilik yapmıştır
Hemen Antik Yunan'dan Orta Çağ'a gelelim.
Orta Çağ'da biraz daha fantastikleşiyor iş
Şöyle deniyor:
Gebe, 20. haftadan itibaren çocuğun
işte ayakları vs. hareketlenmeleri.
Demişler ki Orta Çağ'da da, o 20. haftadan
itibaren, ortalama olarak tabi,
o annenin içeride hissettiği,
karnında hissettiği hareketlenmeler
çocuğun anneyle ilk iletişim kurduğu an
ve ruh kazandığı an, denmiştir.
İşin din boyutuna çok girmek istememekle
birlikte Katolik dinine bakabiliriz,
hemen örnek olarak şu an aklıma gelen.
Onlar da şöyle diyorlar: "Döllenme olduğu
günden itibaren o bir bireydir,
onun hakkı vardır, onun statüsü vardır.
İlk Hristiyanlar da, şimdi öyle de bir
ayrım var malumunuz, ilk Hristiyanlığı
kabul eden alimlerde ise şöyle bir algı
var: "Her döllenen bir mülktür."
Aidiyet hakkı tanırlar.
Tüm dinlerde ortalama bakarsak
genel olarak açıkçası buna,
evet, hepsi oluştuğu ilk andan
itibaren [zigot] bir bireydir.
Bizler bilim insanıyız, gelin işe biraz
mantık, biraz bilim tarafından bakalım
ve ispatlarla konuşalım isterim ben.
Ana rahmine düştüğümüz andan itibaren
birey sayılır mıyız sizce?
Sayılmamamız gerekir değil mi böyle
dediğime göre? Şöyle, bunu ispatlı bir
şekilde konuşalım sizlerle. Ana rahmine
düştüğümüz andan itibaren özellikle ilk
2 hafta içerisinde şöyle tezahür
edebilirsiniz.
Döllenen hücreler bir zar içerisinde
niteliksel olarak birbirlerine benzeyen
yalnızca bir hücre topluluğu.
Herhangi bir fonksiyonu yok.
Dolayısıyla kişinin bireyselleşmesi,
hak kazanması -aramızda hukukçu
arkadaşlarımız da var- 14 günden önce
olmaz, bizler bunu kabul edemeyiz,
elimizdeki bilimsel veriler doğrultusunda.
Nitekim, peki o zaman neden 14?
14'ten sonra ne oluyor diyeceksiniz.
14. günden itibaren bizler şunu
gözlemleriz embriyolojide:
Primitiv çizgi oluşur. Primitiv çizgi,
embriyonun bir kalıntısıdır,
bir işaretidir. Yani embriyo oluşmaya
başlamıştır. O hücre topluluğu, artık
anlam ifade eden bir organizmaya
dönüşecektir demektir
primitiv çizgiyle birlikte.
Primitiv çizginin önemi nedir?
Nöral tüp oluşur. Nöral tüp oluşursa
ne olur İnci? Omurilik gelişir.
Omurilik gelişirse ne olur? Bilinç oluşur.
Dolayısıyla bir bireyi birey olarak
bilim açısından, şimdi hukuk açısından
ahkam tabii ki de kesmek istemiyorum ancak
okuduğum, bildiğim 14. günden itibaren
birey olarak hak tanındıkları açıkçası.
Nitekim baktığımızda embriyonik
kök hücrelerle çalışma şartları arasında
tüm dünyada çok rahatlıkla o 4-5 gününcü
hücrelerden birer birey oluşturabiliriz.
Dolayısıyla bizler için etik kurullardan
geçmek için en önemli kriter, embriyonik
kök hücre çalışanları için, 14. gündür.
Yasalarla da belirlenmiştir Amerika gibi
yerlerde özellikle. Çalışılmayan yerler
var mı? Var. Biraz toplumsal baskıdan,
biraz dinî baskıdan bunu reddedenler var.
Çalışmıyorlar. Ancak en çok çalışanların
Amerika ve Japonya'da olduğunu
söyleyebilirim. Hatta şöyle öngörülmekte,
benim naçizane takip ettiğim, Japonya'nın
Amerika'nın da ilerisine geçeceği yönünde.
Dolayısıyla dediğim gibi bunu bu şekilde
toparlarsak bilimsel açıdan döllenme
sonrası hücre topluluğunun birey olarak
kabul edilebilmesi, yine tartışırız, bu
tartışılır bir konu, primitiv çizginin
oluştuğu döneme denk gelir.
Hiyerarşi... Totipotent'le başladık,
pluripotentle devam edelim.
Pluripotentler ise yine bu bahsettiğimiz
blastosist evresindeler ancak 5-14. gün
arasındaki hücre topluluğu bunlar.
Bunların bizler için önemi nedir?
Ben de pluripotent kök hücrelerle çalıştım
bugüne kadar. Nedir, yani insanlar yana
yakıla... Şu an PopMed'e bakın ben
buraya çıkmadan önce baktım.
385,000 kök hücre makalesi var.
385.000!
Ben tezahür edemedim kafamda onların
çıktısını.
Dolayısıyla şimdi bu pluripotent kök
hücreler özellikle niçin önemli?
Şunlar için önemli: Genetik hastalıkların
moleküler haritalandırılması için
inanılmaz güzel birer laboratuvar
arkadaşları bizler için.
"Disease in a dish" dediğimiz hastalıkları
laboratuvarda tabaklarda üretip takip
edebilmemiz, inceleyebilmemiz, süreci
anlayabilmemize yardımcı olan hücrelerdir.
Pluripotent hücrelerin istisnasız her biri
vücudumuzdaki 200 hücreden herhangi
birine, uygun sinyal verildiği takdirde
dönebilirler.
Dolayısıyla bütün hücreler bizler için
önemli ancak pluripotent kök hücreler
hastalıkların modellenmesinde bizler için
çok büyük önem taşımaktadırlar.
Buradan sonra hiyerarşimizin sonuna geldik
Unipotentteyiz. Unipotent nedir peki İnci?
Şudur arkadaşlar unipotent kök hücreler
vücudumuzda yetişkin hücrelerde bulunan
yerleşik, somatik hücrelerdir. Olmadı,
benim kafamda oturmadı, yine bize örnek
ver derseniz de hemen aklınıza kan
hücreleri gelsin. Alyuvarlar, akyuvarlar,
plateletler, trombositlerimiz... Bunların
hepsi tek bir hücre çeşidi olmuş unipotent
hücrelerdir. Buradan sonra şimdi
embriyonik kök hücrelerden bahsettik,
pluripotensinin öneminden bahsettik.
En sonda anlatacağım anlara girmeden
bir toparlayayım. Bizler için aynı zamanda
2006'dan itibaren literatüre girmiş bir
kök hücre dalı daha var: Uyarılmış
pluripotent kök hücreler.
Induced Pluripotent Stem Cells.
2006 yılında Japon araştırmacı Dr. Shinya
Yamanaka aslında kitapları değiştirdi.
Farklılaşma desem hepiniz bana çok eminim
diyeceksiniz ki şundan şu oluşuyor,
bu gidiyor kemik oluşturuyor, İnci kandan
bu oluşuyor... Hep ileriye doğru bir
farklılaşma algımız var genelde.
Shinya Yamanaka'nın bizlere sunduğu buluş
ile aslında bu kitabi bilgileri değiştiren
geriye farklılaşma, yani ileri doğru
farklılaşmış bir hücreyi geriye doğru,
anne karnında, sizlere az önce bahsettiğim
o embriyonik kök hücre statüsüne
dönebilecek hücrelere döndürmeyi başardı.
Bunları da 2006 yılında fare, 2007 yılında
insanla başardılar. Deri hücrelerini
aldılar, pluripotent kök hücre özelliği
sağlayacak 4 tane çalışma sonrasında
belirledi ve bunları virüslerle aktararak
gerçekten deri hücresini, sonuna kadar
farklılaşmış bir hücreyi, alıp gerçekten
embriyonik kökendeki hücrelerle,
moleküler düzeyleri %100 aynı diyemesek de
o düzeye indirmeyi başarmıştır.
Ve takdir edersiniz ki ödülü paylaştığı
1960'larda çalışmış olan Garden,
klonlamayı da ilk başlatan insan,
kurbağalarda. Ama Shinya Yamanaka 2006'da,
yaptı, 2012'de Nobel aldı. Dolayısıyla
kafalarda tezahür etmesi açısından, bilim
dünyası için onun bulduğu IPS hücreleri
çok büyük bir önem taşıyor.
Nedir peki? Sen çalışıyorsun, sence
avantajları ne. Bir kere çok kolay bir
yöntem. İnanılmaz kolay bir yöntem.
Çok kolay bir şekilde örneği alıp
ben bunu lab ortamında size o
pluripotensi seviyesine çevirebilirim.
Çevirdikten sonra çalışmak istediğim
alana, kalp hücresine, böbrek hücresine
çevirebilirim. İstediğim her şeye
çevirebilirim. Dolayısıyla benim için
bulunmaz bir nimet aslına bakarsak.
Ve etik problem yok. Çünkü onlardan
embriyonik hücreleri nasıl topluyoruz
genelde? Mesela ilk embriyonik hücreyi
izole eden biliminsanının yaptığı şey
bu tüp bebekler için bağışlanan
embriyoların bir kısmı kullanılamıyor.
Akabinde kişiler izin verdiği takdirde,
onlar çalışmalarda kullanılabiliyor.
Bizler embriyonik kök hücrelerle bu
şekilde çalışabiliyoruz. Kafanızda da
herhangi bir yanlış anlaşılma olmasın.
Dolayısıyla bahsettiğim beyefendi de o
bağışlanmış embriyolardan yola çıkarak
ilk embriyonik hücreleri izole etmeyi
başarmıştır. Bizlerin böyle etik kaygıları
olmuyor IPS'de çalışırken, çünkü
saç hücrenizi de alabiliriz, deri
hücrenizi de alabiliriz... Alıp onu uygun
proses ile birlikte ilk basamaklara kadar
indirebiliriz. Böyle avantajı olmasına
rağmen bilimde her şey güllük gülistanlık
değil, böyle yana yakıla savunduğum,
çalıştığım şeyin elbette eksileri var
terazide.
Neler İnci?
Tamam, etik sorunun yok, para sorunun yok
Ama bu sefer de verimlilik düşük,
binde bir başarı alabiliyorsunuz farede,
insanda on binde bir.
Dolayısıyla bazı noktalarda zaman kaybı
da olabiliyor. Verimliliği düşük dedik,
ve tümör oluşum riski yüksek.
Aynı zamanda kök hücreyi eleştiren,
sevmeyen insanların genel bakış açısı
şudur ki içinde bulundurduğu telomaraz
enzimi çok fazla uyarıldığı takdirde kök
hücreler kanser hücresine dönüşüyor.
Sevmeyen de bu sebepten sevmiyor.
Bunlarda da, yani IPS hücrelerinde de
bizler tümör oluşma riskinin fazla
olduğunu biliyoruz.
Toparlayacak olursak çok fazla zamanımı
daha almadan, hemen genel olarak aklınızda
kalmasını istediğim şeylerden bir tanesi
kök hücre tedavileri. Özellikle hangi
alanda olduğunu aklınızda tutmanızı rica
edecek olursam mutlaka diyabet üzerine
çalıştığımızı,kanser üzerine çalıştığımızı
Alzheimer üzerine çok önemli çalışmaların
olduğunu bilin. Ancak bunlar henüz daha
fare aşamasında, deney aşamasında.
İnsanlara da yakında umarım bizlerin de
ömrü yeterse göreceğiz.
Yalnız şunun ben altını çizmek istiyorum,
not alanlarınız var. Kök hücre tedavisinde
kullandığımız kök hücreler.
Şimdi kök hücreleri biz çok farklı
kökenlerden alıp değerlendirebiliyoruz
dedik. Neden? Plastisisite özelliği var.
Ya da IPS hücresi. Ama bizler hangi
hastalıkta isek, hangi hastalıkta
kullanmak istiyor isek o hastalıkla
uyumlu kök hücreleri kullanmalıyız.
Bu buradaki o kırılma noktasıdır.
Bir diğer kök hücrelerin bizler için
sağladığı noktalardan biri, 2D çalışıyoruz
dedik, tabaklarda. 3D yapabiliyoruz artık
Üç boyutlu gözlemler yapabiliyoruz.
Nasıl yapıyoruz? Belli bir kanser
hattınden elde edilen, aslında size
böyle jelatinimsi balon diye tabir
edebileceğim mikro jeller içerisinde
bizler, bahsettiğim embriyonik,
pluripotent kök hücrelerimizi alıyoruz,
orada gözlemleyebiliyoruz.
"Tamam çok güzel,3D görmenin avantajı ne?"
Diyeceksiniz.
Özellikle bağırsak hücreleri mesela,
onlar lümenlidir.
Bizler onları tabakta yaptığımız zaman
ancak gözümüzle iki boyutlu görebiliyoruz.
Ancak o mikrojeller organoidlerin içinde,
yani, ismi organoid. Onların içinde
baktığımız zaman o hücrelerin her yöne
doğru büyüdüğün, diğer hücrelerle
ilişkisini, daha önce görmediklerimizi
görebiliyoruz.
Kök hücrelerin bizim hayatımızdaki önemli
noktalarından, kattıklarından biri de
tabii ki de organoidlerdir.
Bunun dışında, toparlayacak olursak,
hemen aklınızda kalacak... Genç arkadaşlar
çok fazla burada.
Elon Musk, Space X... Değil mi?
Neden anlatıyorsun sen, kök hücre
araştırmacısısın?
İlk kapsülü "Dragon."
Dragon'un içinde birbirinden farklı
her bilim dalından araştırma var.
İki önemli araştırma var.
Mayo Klinik Ekibi'nin başını çektiği,
yürüttüğü.
Ne var o Dragon'un içinde diyeceksiniz.
Unutmanızı istemediğim şey, şu anda
o Dragon kapsülünün içinde, yer çekimsiz
ortamda, kök hücrelerin yaşayıp
yaşayamayacağı, yaşıyorsa nasıl
çoğaldıkları...
Bakın uzayda koloni kurmaya gidiyoruz.
Elon Musk'ın hayalleri.
Bir diğeri kemik doku hasarında
rejenerasyon, yenilenme.
Kemik dokusu hasarında neler olacak?
Orada kök hücreler nasıl hareket edecek?
Yani aslında şu an bizler burada
otururken yerçekimsiz ortamda
kök hücrelerin tabiatları inceleniyor
diyebiliriz.
Çok konuştum.
Son sözümü bence ben, burada lütfen
hepinizin aklında kalsın, daha sonra
izleyecek arkadaşlarımızın da...
Kök hücre dedik, bu kadar insan adı
saydım: Martin Evans, Shinya Yamanaka,
adına verilen ilk ödülü mesela, ilk IPS
klinik çalışmasını başarıyla uygulamıştır,
Takashi Sensei almıştır.
Hep yabancı isimler. Ama benim
sizin aklınızda kalmasını istediğim,
buradan çıktıktan sonra lütfen
araştırmanızı istediğim kişi:
Ordinaryus Profesör Süreyya Tahsin
Aygün.
Kendisi aynı zamanda İstiklal Harbi'nde
de çatışmış olan bir bilim insanı,
bir veteriner, bir Türk veteriner,
bakteriyolog. Dünyada ilk kez "Anthrax"
aşısını geliştiren, bahsettiğim dönemler
50-60'lar, ilk sığır vebasına karşı aşı
geliştiren, ve bizler için önemi:
Türkiye'de ilk hücresel tedaviyi,
kök hücre alanında çalışmalarını yapmış
insandır. Bizlere düşen onun ismini
olabildiğince yüksek sesle dile
getirmektir.
Lütfen onu, buradan çıktığınızda mutlaka
hayatını araştırın derim.
Sona geldik.
Ben konuştum, süreyi uzattım.
Bir yandan da bakıyorlar.
Anlara tutunmak... Burada ben
bu ana sizlerle birlikte tutundum.
Bu sevgililer gününde.
Benim hayatımdaki iki an vardı.
Biri liseye başladığımda, az önce ismini
geçirdiğim IPS teknolojisini bulması.
Herkes soruyor neden kök hücre diye.
Hani spesifik bir nedenim yok!
Olayın çıkma anı gerçekten, o küçük
aklımla, sizin yaşlarınızda...
Neden adamın adını böyle büyük puntolarla
yazıyorlar,neden sürekli bundan bahsediyor
bilim dergileri?Tamamen "adam ne yapmış,"ı
anlamak üzere ben yola çıktım.
Ne yapmış?
O aklımla sizlerin yaşında ben bunu
düşünmek istedim.
Beyefendinin de söylediği gibi,
merak edelim. Meraklarımızın peşinden
koşalım. Yine benim için ikinci önemli an,
birinci anım ne yapmış bu diyerek yola
çıkmak, ikinci anım da üniversiteye
başladığımda Shinya Yamanaka'nın
Nobel alması oldu.
Demek ki bu adam güzel bir şey yapmıştı.
Daha fazla anlamak, işin içine daha fazla
girmem gerekiyordu.
Böyle baktım olaylara.
Ve hayatımdaki önemli iki an,
bununla birlikte üç oldu.
Beni dinlediğiniz için de
çok teşekkür ederim.